all right Ali is with us in Cleveland
Ohio hi Ali welcome to the Dave Ramsey
show hi Dave hey what's up okay so I
have a question I bought my house about
a year and a half ago when I was 21 and
now my boyfriend also has a house and
I'm supposed to be moving in with him
this summer and my question is if I
should rent out my house or if I should
sell it okay so are you getting married
I'm not engaged no okay all right well I
would advise you against that for a lot
of reasons there's a lot of data points
that indicate that people who are
married have a much higher propensity to
succeed in every area of their life
there's all kinds of research that backs
that up and avoid poverty and so forth
just play in house doesn't work you own
a home you've been responsible
you've been financially responsible
beyond your years already and you've
already got a life going here and so I
would suggest I mean I've got kids older
than you so I'm grandpa Dave here right
but uh papa Dave's what the grandbabies
call me but I'm just saying if I'm
talking to a 21 year old version of one
of my kids and I'm gonna say listen
what's this formula for success in life
shacking ups not on the list
okay it's not it's not your it's not the
best thing for you emotionally
physically spiritually financially
career there's no data points to say
that anything is good here except you
get to have sex on a whim that's the
only thing that's available to you that
that's you know that's a positive right
but there everything else everything
else lines up says this is a bad plan
and here you are selling your house or
talking about putting a renter in your
house for a guy that won't even put a
ring on your finger so does that sound
like Papa Dave to you so I'm just on
baby steps for now which is favored
I'm incorrect okay so I have I work for
a school district so I get money put
away for that but also should I be
putting 20% away of my own income as
well no it's 15% and baby step four and
anything out of your income into
something yes I would put 15% away for
retirement above your emergency fund and
your debt free except your home right
mm-hmm and your teacher no I'm a
custodian okay very cool good are you
okay what do you make I'm about 16 and
you're 20 years old
22:22 rocking it way to go
very strong I like it I like it good for
you well done you got a lot you got a
bright future ahead of you let's just
make some careful choices that that make
the young man be a young man okay okay
focus on keeping paying my house down
and yeah I just live there and y'all can
date and if the romance continues and it
moves towards marriage then obviously
when we get married we'd be in the same
house and we can decide which house to
live in and he owns his own home too
yeah
oh that's excellent okay well in the
event where you were to get married I
would sell one or the other and live in
the one that you choose to keep okay but
that's only after marriage okay thank
you thank you for the call we appreciate
you joining us so President Clinton's
domestic policy advisor was a guy named
Bill Galston they did a bunch of
marriage and living together research
among others just to let you guys know
that I'm not just completely crazy here
okay
here's what they found if you do three
things the probability that you will end
up in poverty is almost zero if you
marry before having a child and if you
have your child after age 20 you stay in
what's called the success sequence you
graduate with at least a high school
diploma and you marry before having
children then the chances of you being
being a millennial in poverty
97% of the people who do that do not end
up in poverty 97 percent only 8 percent
of the people I'm sorry 79 percent who
failed to do all 3 will end up in
poverty so there's a lot of data that
indicates that doing things in the right
order old-fashioned I know some of you
don't like it I don't care I'm not here
taking a poll I'm here to help you only
4 percent of homes with a married mother
and father are on food stamps only 4
percent
21 percent of people living together are
on food stamps these are all kinds of
data out there that indicates this
doesn't work when we both have get down
yeah yeah right you're trying to figure
out some way to be the systems that you
can't beat